[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm Rhett and
I'm link today at the round table of dim
lighting we asked the question what if
the day was twelve hours longer what
will we do with ourselves what will we
do with our lives what does that mean
thought how could that even happen
and if scientifically it were possible
oh it it's if geo physically it were
possible
how would that how would that change our
our lives and culture well I don't know
how far-reaching this conversation will
go anywhere but it you know we're
hovering around I mean it may go - it's
about time my friend
maybe time management maybe about
desires and things we never get to who
knows I actually don't know where we're
going with this and that's what's
exciting the question came from another
question that we got on Twitter which
I'm not even gonna talk about now
because we'll talk about that in a
second
a question from a mythical beast that
yeah made us think of this question but
before we get into that I feel it
appropriate to talk to you about an
experience I had last evening
that's I'm gonna I'm gonna start talking
you know one of the things you notice
like when you watch old movies or when
you like looks about the writings of
people who live like a hundred years ago
well their days were 36 hours yeah it
was a different this is a different time
they just spoken better you know what
I'm saying they just they had they the
way I I wish to recall a tale of my last
eve like they how did their brains work
like that I thought sure we're so this
lazy in the way we speak I actually
think it's more of just bad scripting
like what they proper eyes things when
they scripted it ever not capture no
have you ever just read a letter no I
have not read okay all right well yes a
lot a little the way they wrote letters
is not the way that they spoke because
letters were in art form they were it it
was a crafted thing that you sat there
in like it was very eloquent
you know you didn't you didn't have
casual conversation well like that way
with like your you know I believe they
didn't I believe they talked the way
they talked on the Little House on the
Prairie that's how everyone spoke and I
just I missed those days even though I
was not even alive during I don't know
that I've ever watched an episode of
that but I want to talk to you about
some piece of furniture that I attempted
to put together and I know in this in
the previous eve yeah last eve my friend
Neil piece of furniture yes I have a we
about to have a Happy New Year
conversation happen I happened upon a
porcelain furniture a parcel a porcel
it's not work a morsel never was a word
amore part of a cookie a morsel of
furniture no this is not IKEA it could
have been but it wasn't so I don't do
that anymore
the not that I don't look like I never
put together anything in quite some time
in fact some be I'm definitely beyond it
no some of the most simple repairs now
like having had one near-death
experience I'm not I'm not gonna elect
to have another one it's kind of what
it's like you know like in the early
days of home ownership and then in like
the early days of you know right after
we got married we bought a house because
buying a house in North Carolina was
somewhat easier than buying a house in
North Carolina I mean they in California
and after we we bought that house after
a couple years we moved into another
house and started renting out the
original house and I found myself a
landlord and at that point I was doing
I've been kind of told by people who did
this that you've got the only way you
can make money off this is to do all the
repairs yourself so I like learned how
to sheetrock walls and to do plumbing
repairs and like I actually became
relatively handy for like a like a few
years I was relatively handy could do
some electrical work because your time
wasn't worth squat exactly to anyone
else besides you I mean yeah I would try
to fix my
truck I would try that oh yeah I tried
to fix my the intrepid ones I did a
whole dice and stuff yeah I got the
Haynes manual is that what it was the
Haynes auto manual that showed you how
to fix things yeah fix everything but
it's never as simple as tried to change
the timing belt on a Dodge Intrepid and
almost lost a limb
I dropped a huge I opened up the that
the top of the the engine I guess just
to put oil in there but I was trying to
do something else and I dropped a huge
screw in there inside of the engine
block
you're the shakiest man I know under 75
years old I just you doing mechanical
work seems like the worst idea ever
this is I remember I think I told this
story in like Chia Lincoln or something
but I panicked at that moment and I went
to the like the advanced auto and I
found this like telescoping rod that had
a little magnet on the end of it and
Here I am shoving this thing like a
fishing pole down into my engine block
trying to fish out I'm in in the middle
of like all the oil that's how you fish
you stick the pole in the water we can
talk about that later as well trying to
get the magnet to hook onto something
and I never did and then I was like I
just put the cap on it and drive around
and it I guess it just settled to the
bottom it didn't get picked up and it
works its way up so anyway I yeah I
thought we were we were we were past
this we knew you know it's better to
invest in somebody else who knows well
so at this point I get even building
Chester drawers very very small repairs
Jesse is like can you do this and I'm
like nope but you know what baby
you can call whoever you want to do it
III just I don't want to do it you get
somebody to do it but it was my idea so
we've got this this the right if you
walk out of our kitchen you've got the
basketball goal out there and the kids
are just there's just some animals I
mean they're they're just I feel like I
could just have a herd of buffalo and it
would be similar to managing to two boys
yeah I was about to say at least you
don't have three
yeah but your kids are much more like me
organized and they clean up after
themselves thank you you know I mean
your family's different man and so I
think that there's not only is there dog
crap all over this area in his Shepherds
job to clean it up and he doesn't do it
and I end up doing it we got we buy
these basketballs and I buy the
indoor-outdoor basketballs and I say if
you leave this basketball outside in the
Sun it will very quickly disintegrate
into a very non pleasing sphere that no
one wants to touch or play basketball
with it loses his bounce it loses its
grip because the Sun just eats these
basketballs you might as well be talking
to the ball itself yeah and so I said
Jesse I you know we've been in this
house for three and a half years but I
think we need some sort of sports been a
sports been okay to put balls in and I
mean it's gonna make me sound a little
bit like a douche I also recently were
placed might have a one little spot yes
don't say I have to I mean I had to talk
about the hot tub was a lot man no I
actually thought about the hot tub I've
already talked to him about it's already
well-established as security cameras how
much of a douche I am oh and you're
going full I listened I mean I mean I
haven't bought a Lamborghini or anything
so there I have a strip of grass that is
literally 12 feet wide and it's the only
grass I have there's no grass on my
property I just despise it and I wanted
to eliminate the last bit of grass and I
was like hold on you know what I want to
put in some artificial grass because you
don't have to do anything to that you
just put some artificial grass in there
it looks great all the time you don't
have to water it's great for everybody
you're on a slippery slope now and then
I was like even though ironically it's
flat what are you talking about it be a
putting green
[Laughter]
there is I'm sorry I went there you know
I commissioned the construction of a
putting green here's what I'll say
you're right in thinking this if you
were to put 10 men in front of me and
I'm just gonna say men because I'm a man
it could be 10 people if you were to put
10 people in front of me and you were to
say one of these people installed a
putting green at their house and then
the second question is can you pick one
person that you would not like to be
friends with I'd be like well the only
thing I got it going is the guy who had
a putting green assaulted his house I
don't want to I don't want to be friends
with him eliminate it but I am that guy
because I had that done now my dog is
using it as a pooping green and I'm
trying to train her to do it in one of
the cups she hasn't figured that out
yeah that's a bad idea anyway it
actually is really easy to clean the
poop up off of the artificial turf and I
got a little hose installed so I can
like lift and squirt a little lift and
squirt which is what she's doing out
there well the petrified dog poop is
kind of like um what are those fossils
no in golf terms not a bunker but like
an abstruse
wasn't a like an obstacle a hazard a
hazard okay yeah but it's a moveable
it's a you can move torrent putt putt it
could be like bank shot I think if
there's a turd on the green in coffee
you can move it but if there's a turtle
in the fairway you can't move it don't
look around for help
we don't know I don't know the USGA
rules anyway what I do know is that
because now we've got a putter out there
okay you got balls you know what you
need a sport yeah and so I'm on a douche
so I find myself and I have a sports bin
mr. douche on Amazon looking at sports
bins in at this point and I'm about to
pull the trigger I'm about to hit one
click buy a now oh yeah
until my beautiful wife comes over my
shoulder and she's like what are you
looking at and I was like I was gonna
get a sport hop in for the outside she's
like just a random plastic man that
you're gonna put out inside my house
that I just you know I'm worried about
every detail of this
yeah and I say it's just a sport spin
she was like well I wanted to say sports
been on it or was it ugly no it was just
a rectangular black sports bin like like
lift the lid on it it you could also sit
on it as a bench you probably wouldn't
do that but yeah you could okay but mom
the one I was looking at was like 49.99
I mean I was like great deal holds
multiple basketballs Potter and I also
bought myself an electric Leaf Blower
to get the leaves off of the putting
green before I do shout out there before
I go full douche mode and start putting
out there I have to get the leaves off
you could attach your putter to the leaf
blower and that's the same times against
the USGA rules so anyway she decides on
the one and I say you know what I don't
care do you buy it have it as long as it
shipped here and of course she gets one
that cost four times as much $200 and
it's like bigger and cooler and it's got
like a weave disord of wicker design
going on I don't know okay but I noticed
that when I Drive home last night I get
to the bottom of the stairs to walk up
to my house and they have left the
delivery and I see this package that I
know is the sports Ben and what do I
notice about the sports spin package
it's a flat but it's flat and if I don't
if I recall correctly a sports Ben
that's flat cannot hold a basketball hmm
we don't live in old abacus bollock
cannot we don't live in math LAN what
was that book that was all everybody was
2d I don't read I told you that's a
great book by the way
it's like called math Li I know what
you're talking about we had to read it
in middle school everything was 2d
anyway we don't live in that we live in
a three-dimensional world depending on
who you ask and I knew that this was
going to be an evening of me putting
something together mad math land maybe
so I take this thing up to the sports
area and we really we have a sports area
now and a putting green I mean you have
fun for hours and I open up the thing
and it's one of those things that has
what I would call international
instruction
and by that I mean wordless oh just
pictures anybody can do it and I begin
putting this thing together with just
the tools that it came with and you know
you've got a little allen wrench that
fits the very specific screws last night
this is last night and 45 minutes into
this process I'm a little bit upset
because the way you have to like turn
these Allen wrenches and it's up against
this wicker thing and I'm mad that we
didn't get one that's preassembled and
that I'm decided to do this and but once
you just get your mind on something you
just have to do it sometimes well you
don't know what it what don't want to
know what I did last night
okay well we'll find out second I guess
it's breezy okay not a symbol of sports
Ben that's it well you had a better
night than me so then I get thought you
couldn't use like your cordless drill to
replace the allen wrench
well I always do that standby okay I
didn't think it was worth the trip
downstairs because it was they were
moving pretty good but then when I had
to get to the tightening phase I was
like I mean it's just wait to tighten it
so I waited to tighten until I got the
whole thing together then I tightened it
together then I get the lid out and I
put the lid on there and it let me tell
you there's a thought in the back of my
head right as soon as I open this thing
and I was like these two sides are
identical and it doesn't say there's a
difference but I there's I have a
feeling I'm gonna put this whole thing
together and I'm gonna have done it
wrong because I have a tendency to do
these things but that didn't happen
I get the lid to the assembly point I
screw the lid on the last thing I have
to do is take the little hydraulic
little things that keep the lid up when
you open it and I move it down I pull
them down to attach attach them to the
hole that is supposed to be right where
I've pulled them down to and then I look
across the sports bin rather large
sports bin but I can't see the other
side the other side of the sports Ben
has the hole which means that the sides
need to be completely reversed which
means I had to take the whole thing
apart now at this point I was like I
wonder if I could if I have a drill bit
like a star drill bit that will fit this
particular allen wrench and you didn't
explode at that moment before no no you
know what I got I was very upset
but I was like I'm going to calmly go
downstairs and see if I can find a bit
for this and I did have a star bit that
perfectly fitted okay because that seems
like a count to audible ten moment but
it was a thirty minute set back even
with the new tools but let me tell you
right now the sports pin has been put
together there are three basketballs in
there there's a leaf blower in there in
there alright there's so many things
ready to go and I'm just proud of you
that you didn't explode like I would I
mean I probably would have taken every
sports thing that I had and whooped the
tar out of that sports bin cuz it that
stuff just boils my blood I was very
upset about it just based on the fact
that because it's your fault and there's
no one there to well ain't it well I
blame the instruction oh gosh I always
blame the instructions because who else
is there to blame and how did they take
it
they did not respond they just blew away
in the wind but I will say that if I
were to write the instructions for this
particular sports bin yeah I would say
hey buddy make sure you do this side on
this side it because they did it I read
them again
there was no indication you had what you
had to do is you had to look through all
the steps look at the last step see
where it was supposed to attach and then
reverse-engineer go back to the first
step in know where to put it and that's
asking too much of me I'm just a dad who
hasn't put together a sports been in
years
you know should've got somebody to do it
lesson learned won't do it again I'm
going back to being nan handy well
you're about to have a lot more time on
your hands a lot of time to potentially
put together sports bins or whatever
else we're gonna do because I don't know
if you heard but days are gonna start to
be 36 hours now I heard about this at
least in our mental exercise that we're
about to have but first we want to let
you know that you could pick up this
wonderful softest sweatshirt I've ever
put on let me just tell you that right
now I absolutely love the softness of
this soft on the outside soft thudding
if you don't like hard sweatshirts hard
crusty sweatshirts and you'll love this
army green good mythical morning
sweatshirt available at mythical
store I'm so cozy right now along with
other stuff rep your mythical miss
mythical dot still the reason we're
talking about this is because we got a
reply on Twitter from Chris crystal
melody right now I am thinking what the
world would be like if days were changed
to 36 hours long instead of just 24
hours I'd probably still procrastinate
is what she said thank you for that
question crystal that has sparked some
thoughts in our minds so I'm curious
listener at this point are you are you
experienced in an avalanche of things
that you would do ways that you would
occupy your life ways that you would
change your life if every single day
from here on out it was 50% longer at 12
more hours if I'm doing the math right
allow me to wrestle with that because if
my first response has just allowed me to
wrestle with it oh my gosh like it's not
like yes finally
it's like trepidation how come I get now
I have more time to figure things out
maybe I'll just so that says a lot about
you yeah it does I approach this from
Irvine No
very different standpoint so mine my
like knee-jerk gut reaction is just
sleep the rest of it oh gosh don't don't
try to figure anything else
well okay from a scientific standpoint
just to get this out of the way I don't
want to talk about this too long but I
am interested in this a you would sleep
significantly longer well I want to go
even even more scientific like the
geology and the earth without earth
itself would be big right I'm getting to
that
well it doesn't this the size of the
earth it would rotate is relative well
it would have to rotate slower right but
I you know that the the length of the
day is based on the time that it takes
for the earth to completely rotate one
time on its axis and
that time is actually getting slower
with every year that passes I don't know
what the exact fraction is that's like
175 thousandth of an of a second or
something like that but it's so sweet
but it's it's enough and what's
happening is the moon is actually
causing the moon is moving away slowly
which is causing the earth to slow down
over time hearing that makes me sad I
don't know exactly what this means is
actually days I think again don't quote
me on the math but like a billion years
ago so like before there was any people
way before there was any people days
were like hours different in length like
they were hours shorter because the days
are cuz the earth is slowing down so
therefore the days are getting longer so
I think it's like five hours longer or
something like that a billion years ago
you can look up the specifics but wow
it's pretty crazy that what we are
first of all life on Earth evolves in
the context of the length of the day and
the night and basically everything about
our life cycle and also the length of
the year we've kind of talked about that
before but you sleep approximately the
amount of time that is dark you know
give or take but that you on a planet
out there where the day is a different
length which planets even within our
solar system two days or different links
if you evolved if a life-form evolves on
that planet your sleep cycle would be
relative to where you're at so yes if it
was 36 hours and let's say you be so if
right now it's 24 hours you sleep eight
hours so 36 hours you'd probably sleep
12 hours you'd sleep a third of the time
so you beat so four additional hours
would be you sleeping and you're
biologically what you would have evolved
in that way but you still have an extra
hour you wouldn't be a lazy slog that
would just be how happy how you evolved
right but so I don't feel that bad about
and also our capacity for anything that
we would do during the day would be
relative and we would fill the time
based on economic factors and all that
stuff and the length of the workday and
our capacity for it would be relative so
I don't actually want to think about
that because that's just basically
stretching something to scale and
filling it with the same amount of time
the more interesting exercise is to say
what if all of a sudden you and me all
of us had 12 extra hours during the day
that we would not beat at tired and I
think for me as a rule I'm going to say
I'm not just gonna fill it with more
work I'm saying that like I would work
the same amount that I do now and I
would sleep the same amount that I do
now but I've got 12 completely extra
hours what would I do is I but just a
camp out on that for a second I am
curious if yes we snapped our fingers
and then all of us experienced this
extra daylight that could be working
hours would something about competition
I can only let it's easy to speak about
our jobs but maybe we can extrapolate is
there something about competition that
you would just fill it with more work
because well you're not tired and you
can get you can get more productivity
and you can be more competitive and you
can make our money or you can you can
chase that devil chase that devil of
possessions in and and fleeting
happiness and what you can buy of course
I'm sure
that's what of course or powerful I mean
I think that it this is the waste all
over the world
Americans are probably the are one of
the best examples of people who have
just filled their time with as much
trying to get ahead as they possibly can
and I'm not saying this is a good thing
I'm knowing it is a fact there are other
cultures who have said you know what
we're gonna work for days or we're going
to work six hour days we're gonna work
five hour days right we've pushed
ourselves to the limit and so we've kind
of up against this wall and this is how
I feel and this is why this question
intrigued me so much is because even
just recently and again I'm not trying
to do the the whiny thing about I'm so
busy I can't stand when people say how
busy they are and I end up doing it all
the time so I'm not talking about how
busy I am I'm just talking about the
fact that I have fallen into the trap of
sort of the American Dream and doing
something I love to do doing this job we
get to do we were living the dream we're
getting to do exactly what we want to do
but I have like that moment that I had
last night
when I was sitting there incorrectly
putting together the sports been one of
the reasons it was so frustrating is
because I was like I don't have this
time needed me I don't have yeah half an
hour at night to sit around and
incorrectly put together a sports bin I
didn't have time to put together the
sports button to begin with because I'm
at home and I would actually like to be
spending the time with my family or
enjoying a television program with my
wife you know what I'm saying but sted
you build it twice exactly because we
I've already filled my time she called
me I would have gladly and come over and
help you build it and probably not I'm
glad you didn't call me you know what I
tried to get you to help me put the
basketball goal up actually I said when
we had that party and my other friends
there and some of them were taller than
me
yeah we know so I bought this new
basketball goal because the old one was
was was too rusty remember and I was
like I looked at the package and said
definitely do not try this without two
people I was like okay crap and so I was
having a party in my house and when you
guys got over there everybody's kind of
like hanging out around the basketball
going it's like hey guys I got a new one
you want to help me put it up it was
like a barn raising that's it yeah
that's my idea of a party but you guys
didn't come to my party oh you guys did
not respond like the Mennonites let me
tell you right now you were not helpful
so a couple of them were you got I
didn't end up working because anyway the
UH know what happened the next day I did
it by myself with a 6-foot stepladder
and a broom and I was doing all this
thing propping things no I thought that
Nick and Joseph felt you helped you put
it up they couldn't we didn't do it oh
it didn't work well I didn't know that I
ended up doing it myself
and I almost died but thanks a lot so
what do you have a definitive answer
about did something immediately pop into
your head or was it like yes this is
what I've been waiting for 12 more hours
well well we're talking about four more
hours of daylight that's what we're
calling it no I'm saying twelve
hours because I think I'm sleeping the
same amount okay okay I don't have
definitive answers of what I would do
but okay so I've plugged Josh Sundquist
a friend of ours a number of times in
his what I he made that the video we
talked about the germ method uh-huh
je RM the things that he wants to do
every single day he writes to write in
his journal he wants to exercise he
wants to read and he wants to meditate
in addition to all the other things that
he's gonna do and I was just like that's
great because those are the things I
like to fill my time with if I'm able to
write both of us have kind of we've
gotten into meditation on a meditation
light like a flirt with it we're like we
have an app you know like we're the guys
with the app and have been known to like
dad's out next to the pool sitting
crisscross applesauce
what's he doing out there you know
everybody you you might have a similar
experience but it's not like you're a
daily meditator nor am i oh no I have I
have a journal you know I mean I
actually use my Evernote I go in and I
write ideas and I write things that are
happening in my life but I do it how
often a couple of days a month maximum
right I do exercise a few times a week
not every single day and I end up
reading but the vast majority of what I
read is just the internet man it's not
sitting down with a book that usually
happens on vacation when I've got time
off when I kind of sit down and get into
a book so I don't do those things so the
first thing that I thought is I was I
was like okay I would actually do those
things and when you talk about
exercising I know you go to you go to
the gym I go to the gym different gym
different gyms what we call it dead at
the same gym one one gym is like four
studs the other gym is for like tall
guys with beards yeah I go to an
exclusively tall guys with beards gym
they are all incredibly buff I was
really trying to emphasize the stud part
and then try to be very clear who I was
talking well I used to go to your gym
and
I'm saying anything about it
studs it's not how I would describe the
clientele but it's cool it's cool I mean
that you I'm say I'm glad you feel that
way look at me man and so one other
thing I thought about the way that I
approach my time at the gym again my
time at the gym is like incredibly
scheduled right it's like okay I'm gonna
go I've got this class so if you have
more time you just go hang out at the
gym well okay stay with me here because
in my gym I I know you're the studs Gym
they don't have like a locker room and
you know a steam room and you don't get
a eucalyptus towel and when you get done
with your workout I mean in my gym those
are the kinds of things that we have oh
yeah gym or people who have putting
greens at their home okay but anyway I
have sort of made this decision that
when I get done with my workout I'm
going to if I have time I'm gonna go and
spend like 10 minutes in the steam room
because I just love that feeling there's
other people in there and they are
having conversations but I've kind of
opted out of the whole gym friend thing
right and then I go back to my locker
I'm gonna take a shower then I go to my
locker and I'm changing clothes and
there's like a couple of people who I
have very on a very surface level just
they're an acquaintance and they maybe
asked me about like one guy was like
where'd you get those shoes one time and
I told him and because he's the where
did you get those shoes guy now if I get
a locker next to him I'm like what's up
man and then he'll ask a question I'll
answer it but then not ask another
question because I don't want a gym
friend you know what I'm saying because
I got to get out of I got to get out of
there this is about getting in there
this is about working out a little bit
getting some steam and then going on
about my business but one of the things
I was thinking about is if I have more
time I might develop a gym friend like
what if I were to ask what are those
where'd you get those shoes where'd you
get those shoes from guy another
question
like where'd you get those shoes from oh
now we're getting somewhere
so with 12 more hours in the day you
would ask a follow-up question about a
dudes shoes
the gym that's exactly what else you
would turn the gym into like a social
zone No oh that might be overstating it
what I'm saying is that I have made a
conscious slash unconscious decision to
minimize conversation and relationship
at the gym because I see it as this
little window of time which I got to get
out and get here yeah to take care of
business
I don't have time and I could okay I'm
sure you have an equivalent equivalent
experience because I know you're working
out with people who don't necessarily
have to be somewhere right after they
finish working out I actually left my
class wasn't over today and I had to
leave and the instructor was like where
you going I was like I gotta take my son
to school and I got to leave right now
I'm gonna do that so I can get here for
my mime and you know every I feel like
every second of my day is is scheduled
absolutely and yeah I just you know I I
have this problem membrane that I feel
like okay if if I'm not efficiently
using every second of my day I'm just
not doing the right thing you know I'm
I'm not being
I'm not aspiring to perfection and it's
you know that's very it's very unhealthy
you know to not allow space for surprise
and experience in relationship and but
how could you turn it about shoes but I
mean well I don't think I could change
that without the extra time and in this
case 12 hours so I might have a one-hour
conversation just about shoes with a
half-naked man at a gym that's the kind
of thing that would start happening in
my life and who knows where that would
lead
well when you talked about the the
meditation thing is interesting that you
started there I think our minds are in a
similar place because that is where that
is one of the first things I thought of
when I move past anxiety and again
that's that's where the way that my
brain works something so positive as
extra time which is basically free
unstructured time it's seen impulsively
as a negative because I don't yeah
know the perfect plan you're intimidated
by the work do you have to do in order
to fill the time well to know what the
right answer is and again that's the
problem but what with 12 hours you can
get things wrong the question about
shoes with a half-naked man is an
example I was making a point a sting
time that's how my that's how my brain
works and at least I'm aware but I'm
talking about an extra hour 12 extra
hours a lot of hours so then my first
answer is I think for Prabha at least
and I would probably make up my mind at
the front end of this once I realized
well earth is rotating slower
I have approximately 12 hours every day
that I was going to spend X amount of
hours every day for six months in silent
solitude how much time X amount of time
I don't know what that number is every
single day every single day well yeah
for like III think sick I think two
hours a day for six months
why just six months once you do it for
six months it's just part of your
routine I don't know what would come of
it like I'm so far from knowing what
that would do I'm and like that it that
would be a form of meditation or many
different forms I don't know well this
meditation reflection let's talk and
then I think I might move on to
something else or decide to do something
or maybe I would have come to the
conclusion by that point I need to set
an end goal I need to set a goal but
then perhaps I will have reached the
conclusion by then that like I need to
increase that number I don't know well I
want to talk about meditation that's how
I would approach I want to talk about
meditation because we we both again and
flirted with it and again let me tell
you one of the things about being small
town boys from North Carolina who moved
to California is we're able to hear
through the lens of small town boys from
North Carolina when people from
California talk so again that's why we
qualify things with douche like douche
qualifiers and I understand that a lot
of people as soon as they hear things
like they're talking about meditation
what happened these guys
I acknowledge that there's this
descendancy to be like what do you what
you guys talking about
frou-frou meditation but meditations is
incredibly old concept that exists
across many different traditions and has
been its unequivocal it's completely
scientific the benefits that you can get
from it but I gotta say it's very
difficult to do and to be good at it and
to benefit from it and the and I think
the average American and I consider
myself the average American when you
first kind of try it you're like what
what do you mean what do you mean sit
here and focus on my breath what are you
talking about and I can't do that I'm
thinking about 55 different things at
the same time and I know while we're
different we're also very similar in the
way we approach things like that and the
way we approach that kind of time and I
think the way that we would struggle
with it when we sit down to try to go
through it but what I have found and I
think the longest that I've ever like
set down and meditated again this is
like a guided meditation so you've got
somebody in your ears kind of talking
you through it it's probably like 45
minutes and again that's not just one
thing the entire time that's somebody
saying okay now think about this or
focus on this or but anyway it has this
incredibly calming effect and very
rarely are you gonna meet somebody who
practice and practices meditation on a
regular basis for long periods of time
who's just an [ __ ] or on it you know
what I'm saying on as much edge as I
yeah there's a reason that the people
who are able to spend I mean there's
some people who spend hours a day maybe
like that what that's crazy
what a waste of time but the level of
peace that those people have in their
lives and the level of peace that
they're able to impart to the people
that they interact with let me tell you
right now my wife and children would
love for me to spend more time in
peaceful meditation because the net
effect would be that I would be a more
peaceful and meditative person when I
wasn't having
direct peaceful meditation so for me
that the idea of being able to do that
and to and first of all if you're
interested in it headspace is not a
sponsor hopefully will be at some point
that they've got a great app for for
kind of getting you an introduction yeah
into and - and there's other apps as
well but headspace has been been been
good in terms of guided meditation but
that for me that's a big one I feel like
the very first thing I would do is I
would like fine like I have a
comfortable place meditation cushion you
know the right environment and I would
actually spend an extended amount of
time in meditation every single day to
begin with yeah and this is a great
question because it's a it's a daily
habit question it's not like because I
started thinking well I'm gonna I'm
gonna I'm gonna take a trip or I'm gonna
walk the earth well no I have okay I've
got responsibilities I've got I've got
loved ones and interactions in a career
and you know even friends but it said
even friends so it's not the type of
thing that it's like okay what becomes a
new party of my life I I also have have
thought specifically about having more
time with the kids it's like being a
part of their life you know it's it's
something that Kristi and Jesse like
they were they were home school and they
were so much arguably the center of
their our kids lives you know and and
they're older now they're they're in
school but you know who picks them up
most the time who's there the moment
they come out of school and like
whatever happened that day they're the
ones that they experience that by the
time I get home you know Chrissy's just
telling me what they dumped on her that
they don't have the energy to explain to
me again it's like well I told one
parent isn't that good enough like can't
you guys just communicate like I read
and I
relate to that like when something
happens to me it at work or something
good bad indifferent it's not like I
want to tell the exact same story to
every family member even though I love
each of them and I want to share my
lives with them so that's something I've
been thinking about and talking to
Christy about is you know I the the
times where I do hear this is what
happened today that you missed or just
appreciating the sheer volume of time
that they spend together that that I
don't get to like wow they're gonna be
gone before I know it you know and if
all of a sudden I had that much more
time
I think I'd very quickly be shifting my
schedule and saying okay when when more
their waking hours let's have an overlap
so we can hang out so that you know our
lives overlap more then me just getting
home for dinner and then for a weekend I
think there would be and first of all
not to get to the end of this but I
already have in my mind where this
conversation is going to lead and to
what the application is that I think
it's it's pretty interesting pretty
interesting exercise but I think that
what would inevitably happen is if
you're in if you're a family person is
that you would end up having there be
family time it might be like the family
hour or something you would end up
naturally spending time you spend more
time with your spouse like the way that
our time is divided up and this is this
is probably true of many different
couples but like you know if you're
married with kids how often you go on a
date some people are really disciplined
about this and they have like a weekly
date night that's something that I know
both of us have had at times but never
to for too long because if you don't
keep it super consistent it just you
just don't end up doing it and so I
think that having something like that on
a daily basis it would be so much easier
to have that on a regular basis with it
with this extra time you'd end up having
this I'm gonna have a purposeful
connection and this is interesting
because in my relationship with my wife
she is much more like
to be the one to want to initiate like
let's have a conversation that is solely
intended for us to connect right mm-hmm
and it's not that I don't want to talk
about those and talk about that and talk
about our relationship it's just I kind
of gravitate towards like oh if I'm
gonna talk to you I'm gonna talk I'm
gonna talk to you about something that
happened at work or some idea that we're
working on or whatever and then she's
like but yeah but let's have a
conversation about us or let's have a
conversation where the purpose of the
conversation is not to communicate
information or to solve a problem it is
legitimately to to connect with one with
another with one another and that
doesn't end up happening nearly as much
as I would like it to and especially as
she would like it to right and the same
thing with kids it's like same you feel
like oh I'm gonna sit down at dinner and
I do usually eat dinner with the kids we
all sit down and eat dinner together
when we when we can which is multiple
times a week every week and I'll be like
tell me about school and you know the
answers you get to that question ah
nothing she got to find like a more
specific question where like was there
something good that happened was there
something bad that happened did you make
a new friend did you lose a friend what
like you try to find ways to get your
kids to talk to you and like I said well
they've kind of talked to mom about that
when she picked him up from school and I
definitely think that was the
relationships with your immediate family
would be something that would fill that
gap but another thing is relationships
with friends now we've got some great
friends and we in a lot of ways share a
friend group that we end up hanging out
with on a regular basis and in a very
unusual sort of non 20:18 non Los
Angeles way we actually found a way to
connect with our friends on a regular
basis because we schedule time together
like we've actually regularly scheduled
times for us to get together and hang
out which is like been an incredible
thing I know yeah for both of us and for
others in the group it's just been
great to be able to have a group of
friends that you can hang out with on a
regular basis and actually get into each
other's lives and sustaining a point
learn about learn about each other it
kind of get through life together that's
been something that's been so beneficial
and so great but still it's scheduled
and it's like at best weekly and then
you know I I do the my like we my
monthly game night that you and Christy
are part of that is like a bigger circle
circle of people like 25 people if they
all come and they never all come which
is like I love that I instituted that
time and I told Jessie last year I was
like I want to do a game night because
hey I'm super competitive and I love to
play games and be I have this like group
of friends from all over the city that I
know from different parts of my life and
I think they would be super fun to bring
together into an environment I just want
to hang out with them on a regular basis
and in Los Angeles monthly is a regular
basis to see somebody that's seeing
somebody a lot but I think that if I had
12 hours and everybody had 12 hours some
sort of like connection with with
friends again you can't fill it with
more work nobody's feeling it with more
work nobody's sleeping more you didn't
have spending more time with friends you
didn't have filling that time with
relationships
maybe the guy who likes my shoes the gym
but hopefully just the people I want to
connect with already yeah it it's
interesting to me that it still comes
down to scheduling like I think that
anything worth prioritizing I don't know
if this is just me or from the
experience you just described but I feel
like even things that are very important
to me if I don't schedule them they
don't happen I mean we talked about the
the date night that we each had with our
have other wives and like do you
currently have a scheduled date night no
but like we're almost about to get that
going again because it involves
childcare and like figuring that out so
having some having someone that you've
said I'm a pay you to to free me up to
be able to
do this you know so we got that
Logistics we got those logistics figured
out but it it drifts you know like every
life happens and things shift and all of
a sudden something that you're so
excited about and that you're totally
want to prioritize still doesn't happen
so what I'm getting at is even when you
have all this time I think it still has
to be scheduled and I think I would even
have to schedule just the surprise time
just to go with the flow and talk about
shoes time schedule surprise time
yeah just glad you'll spawn taint
spontaneity schedule spontaneity and
it's like what's gonna happen now
because it sounds like a t-shirt you
should wear I scheduled spontaneity you
know what there's probably a lot of
people who would buy that
write that down well I think I know for
me I got an appointment for spontaneity
I it sounds funny but I think I need
that maybe that's not for everybody it's
probably not but I know that's how it
works for me and I'm so far from being
able to afford to just have scheduled
spontaneity there's like no plans
whatever happens happens whatever I feel
like at this moment like I can do that
like I don't I don't know how that or it
makes me think of and I don't remember
who this was so we're no one's gonna get
in trouble
somebody who knew about another content
creator schedule was talking to us about
what they were doing and like trying to
schedule something for them or with them
or something like that and they they
like literally sent them their calendar
and every single day had a huge chunk
like at least four hours maybe six hours
on some days and the chunk was labeled
unstructured creative time every single
day and we heard about that and we were
like I mean you're like what would that
be like like to say you know structured
creative time you know what I'm gonna do
Wow I'm a goat I'm a go to a museum I'm
just gonna walk around and I might
invite a friend or a loved one or you
know family member or just go by myself
you know it's like there's so much of
that here but I haven't done that
I think you know I this is my corollary
do you really have to have if that's the
case that everything needs to be
scheduled and maybe this is just for me
if I even if I had 12 more hours in a
day well isn't there a way for that to
be headed for that to happen now
you know like isn't there some of the
spirit of what we're talking about that
can be applied to our actual real lives
and so I you have an idea where where
you want to go and well maybe that was
that was it oh that was the oh that was
that was the inevitable conclusion of
our conversation but I do have a sit I
have a step along the way to get to that
because one of the things I think we're
talking about because we could talk
forever about what we would do at 12
extra hours I mean I would read a lot
because I love to read I would write I
would write in a journal like a
journalistic like self-discovery sort of
way I think I would spend time just
sitting there thinking I would have
unstructured creative time that was not
necessarily geared towards contributing
something to our business but like
there's a whole slew of things that I
would love to create that would not be
beneficial to us yeah as an example you
know I'm saying like there's like if I
just if I told you that I wanted to go
and paint you'd be like how do we sell
that your paintings a mythical does
store and I'd be like well that's that I
just want to paint I can't get in I
can't get to a place where I just paint
it could call it bad paintings and but
if myself I have you of course I've
thought about painting I've walked
through craft stores and seen the
painting section and gotten this close
12 times to buying a canvas and all the
stuff because I thought I might paint
now I haven't done that for number of
reasons but one of the reasons is
because well there's a whole list of
creative things that I want to do that
are part of what we're doing a mythical
entertainment that we haven't gotten to
let alone the things that I just want to
do just creatively let alone the things
I just want to think about you know I'm
saying man and let alone that there's
with that much time you have so much
more capacity to do good you know it's I
mean it sounds like an obligatory
auditioning that up but I mean it it is
here it works and it's one of those
things that I think that once once you
allow yourself to serve you gain so much
more from it so I believe that service
has a selfish component that's that's
justified that like it's good for
everybody I think about culturally if
you know if people who were at a loss
with what to do with themselves were
more mobilized to serve together so I'm
even building from just one person like
from me like volunteering to a culture
of well we can't work week let's not sit
on our bums and and and you know fight
depression let's get active yeah and
serve that that's it that's an exciting
thought that what we could accomplish
I mean oh we if we just slow the
rotation down a little bit all of a
sudden we got all the service blossoming
that would be amazing
of course I don't know what other
scientific repercussions there would be
that would make to make this whole thing
Kareem off but like I said if it
continues to happen at a slow pace that
it is happening we're just gonna
continue to fill it with the same BS
that we already fill our lives with but
it's we're gonna continue on the same
hamster wheel but and it's hard to even
have space to say how can I engage my
heart and my passions in something that
is outward focused and that is not even
about the the exciting aspect of
expression which by the way all those
things had come together you know your
bad paintings could could could uh I
don't know somehow being in in resulting
in a lot of good I don't understand how
that would happen
socially I meet that you'd have time to
figure it out okay so one of the things
that
I think we're been flirting with as well
is we're having this conversation you've
heard me talk about this a lot because
I've gotten it from other people but you
know we're essentially Stone Age
software running all modern-day hard
sorry Stone Age hardware running modern
day software meaning that we have the
bodies in the brains and the
capabilities of people who did not have
anything to do with the modern society
that we have now but we're pushing
ourselves through this but these bodies
that we have for most of existence human
existence you know you go back to
hunter-gatherer days and they actually
you know they were in small groups of
people about a hundred and fifty or so
or less and they had meaningful
relationships with not only their
immediate family but the people who they
were in a tribe with and yes they spent
a lot of time gathering food because
when you're gathering and hunting you're
spending a lot of time gathering and
hunting but it was pretty much taking
the time to serve to survive they spent
most of their time surviving but they
relied on one another they spent lots of
time talking to one another doing good
for one another they spent a lot of time
killing each other I'm not trying to
paint this speaking of painting a
picture yes they killed each other it
droves humans have always done that but
the time was structured so much
differently than in our time now that we
are in this capitalistic modern society
where we're constantly just pushing
ourselves to create and produce and make
the pie bigger and bigger and the
population is growing and all the things
that contribute to modern society and
the hamster wheel that we're in that
didn't exist because you basically lived
a life where you did exactly the same
thing that your mom and dad did that
their mom and dad did their mom and dad
did their mom and dad did it was the
same technology it was the same goals
for generation after generation after
generation after generation because
technology changed so so slowly there
would be like one invention in like a
hundred generations I mean it was crazy
how slow things move for so long and
even though the days were
a little bit shorter back then not much
few seconds probably are a few minutes
life was a lot different and I think
that a lot of these things that we're
talking about like self reflection like
sitting there and thinking or spending
time with your family
you didn't say hunter-gatherer people
who weren't like man I need to spend
more time with my my family they were
probably a bit more like I need to get
away from these people are the only
people I'd see all the time so I think
that's part of our problem is that we
haven't changed biologically but we were
trying to adapt to this environment and
it's resulting in people getting
incredibly stressed out depressed
getting all kinds of diseases being
sleep deprived all the things that
happen but I was exactly on the same
page that you were what you said a
second ago which is if the first things
that we talk about when we say that we
would have extra time is well I would
meditate every day I would read every
day I would spend more time getting to
know people I would spend more time with
my family it's been more time with my
friends I'd spend more time just
thinking I spend more time creatively
pursuing things that fulfill me well
we're not gonna get those 12 hours but
we have the power you have the power to
make decisions that introduce those
things into your life on a regular basis
it will not come without sacrifice and I
think the question is is like well what
are you willing to let go of yeah my
answer
Lync I think I have to quit I think I
got to stop doing your biscuits because
this is time I could be spending with my
family oh gosh
did he just say that no I'm not gonna do
that I'm not gonna give this up I'm not
gonna stop making that internet show
that we met of course I'm not gonna do
that well the thing that we don't like
to do on this podcast is be prescriptive
because maybe it's obvious over the
course of the course of this
conversation that we didn't know where
was going we did not talk about it ahead
of time much less say this is the point
we're trying to make for you you know I
you know I could say well you're a you
know you're a student or you're working
a nine-to-five
or you're working a lot more than that
or you have these demands or these needs
or these problems and these restrictions
on your life you don't have the luxury
to say well I would just like to read
more so I'm gonna make I'm gonna make an
adjustment you know I I we're not trying
to read your mind and be prescriptive to
your situation
we're just verbally processing ours
which I mean we are in a very I'm very
grateful for the works extremely
fortunate for the for the position that
we're in that we you know it's we we run
a business and we're creative and we're
yeah we're things we said before you
know we're living our dream doing
engaging our passions and doing them by
and large what we want to do then when
it gets down to the nitty-gritty of it
sometimes it doesn't feel like that a
lot of times it doesn't feel like that
it feels like an obligation that it
seems like it's external forces even
though it's something that we have set
up and that we're altima lee in charge
up but once you set this thing in motion
it doesn't feel that much different than
just something that's like something we
something someone else is in control and
I you know I think it's
it's our wives remind us of that all the
time you're the boss you don't you you
can take the day huh oh yeah and then
what you don't understand
and it's like well I don't I don't think
maybe we don't understand well but no
but I agree with your point because we
say it in a very privileged naive
position in a lot of ways you know I I
met we met a guy on this recent little
mini tour who was a truck driver it was
like I listened to your biscuits while
I'm driving
mm-hmm met a guy who's a postal worker
it was like I listened to I listened to
your biscuits on my route thank you for
thank you for ear biscuits because you
know it fills this time and I think
people who are doing you know some
people are working 12 hours a day maybe
more to provide for somebody for some
people and they do they don't have the
luxury in order to continue to pay to
live to pay to eat they have to continue
working an incredible amount of hours I
mean that is the the situation that a
lot of people find themselves in so
they're not able to say I'd like some
unstructured creative time because well
if I get unstructured creative time
somebody's not going to eat we're not in
that situation and we recognize that a
lot of people are so I think that that
really just highlights a deeper problem
with our society and I don't listen I
don't claim to be economic
socio-economic expert I don't understand
I have lots of different opinions about
stuff and how it should work but
ultimately I don't know what the
solutions are but I know for a fact
we've gotten ourselves into a situation
where people are doing things and we
develop habits and we've made we've made
certain we've created obligations as a
species which are not healthy and if you
have the the option to kind of step out
of that step off of that hamster wheel
and actually
begin to kind of chip away at some of
the things that you think you've made
you're responsible for you know I was
talking to my therapist about this like
when we talked about meditation I was
like I just want to make it a part of
every single day and he was just like
you just have to make the decision that
it's not negotiable but I'm still living
in this world where it's so easily
negotiated away because I can sleep a
little bit longer and I can justify
saying I need to sleep a little bit
little bit longer mm-hmm you know so I
don't I don't know I don't know what the
process of chipping away and getting
some of that time back
you know besides actually making the
earth slow down which i think is gonna
be very difficult for us to figure out
it's probably gonna take more time than
we have to figure that out we've got the
time we've got 24 hours in a day we have
to we have to be intentional in some way
to get some get some time back but
today's 24 we'll never get back right
nope well thanks for hearing us out yeah
good luck good luck with that is a great
mug to have on the table because I think
we've just highlighted a big problem in
our in our species in our society in our
own lives and maybe your life and just
said good luck with that we don't really
know what you should do maybe
commiserating is is the first step let
us know what you think or commiserate
using hash tag ear biscuits we can keep
the conversation going amongst all of
you as well as with us and we will speak
at you next week yeah oh maybe we won't
I have an idea this is the last day of
this could ever let's take the last 10
minutes
for starters of every podcast and just
have a mindfulness meditation
we're gonna have to press play on that
app because we wouldn't know how to do
that no it'll just be silent Oh for for
the listeners and for us and but it
would force us to do it it's like Lauer
monetizing our meditation that's
beautiful what if we did that that's the
spirit what if we did that before we
started recording no I wanted to be part
of the show what if we just played ads
while we well we meditate I think what
would happen is we would we would have
minutes of ads it's worth it because
we're meditating we waited silently walk
off well there's a video version I was
gonna say we silently walk off and just
make this just run it for 10 more
minutes Kiko and just say that we're
here meditating mmm you can be there
meditating no you're basically just I'm
about creating a guided meditation I
mean not Gaia silent that exists I mean
it you're basically talking about
creating nothing it's just you're
talking about creating the absence of
something which is not creating anything
at all I'm talking about creating a 10
minute audio file of silence at the end
of whatever conversation we had but what
if instead of creating a 10 minute file
of audio silence you just said sit there
for 10 minutes after this is over then
we wouldn't sit here for 10 minutes we
would go off and work but we could and
just not record it that's no fun man
what a conundrum to watch more ear
biscuits click on the playlist on the
right to watch the previous episode of
your biscuits click on the playlist to
the left and don't forget to click on
the circular icon to subscribe if you
prefer to listen to this podcast it's
available on all your favorite podcast
platforms thanks for being your mythical
best